acting is a profession that requires a
lot of versatility and willingness to
test boundaries in the act of immersion
sometimes the script calls for things
that the actor himself would never even
consider yet they have to play it
naturally and sometimes that results in
a complete nightmare for everyone
involved here are some movie scenes that
actors regret doing a Titanic drawing
may be the most memorable scene in
Titanic is the one where Kate Winslet's
ROS character asks Leonardo DiCaprio's
jack to draw me like one of your french
girls it's a passionate moment showing
her character overcoming the disapproval
of her fiance and mother to claim her
own agency and embrace the man she's
fallen in love with as a paying customer
I expect to get what I want
but now obsessive fans try to get
Winslet to sign pictures of herself
naked and she'd love for that to stop
she told Yahoo News quote I don't sign
that picture it feels very uncomfortable
why would you do that and quote why
indeed give that man a shirt Taylor
Lautner played the werewolf character
Jacob in the Twilight series and his
transformations usually left him
shirtless if not completely naked fans
loved it but laudner worries now that
his pecs might overshadow his acting he
told a showbiz quote if I had to choose
I would never take my shirt off again in
a movie but I guess that's not very
realistic I certainly won't be asking to
do it though
end quote a change of heart in the 2013
action comedy kick-ass 2 Jim Carrey
plays a superhero called Colonel stars
and stripes whose gruesomely murdered by
supervillains a few months after the
film was released Carey publicly
condemned the level of violence in the
film after experiencing a change of
heart in the aftermath of the tragic
Sandy Hook massacre which happened
shortly after he'd wrapped up filming
his scenes quote I did kick ass to a
month before Sandy Hook and now in all
good conscience I cannot support that
level of violence I am not ashamed of it
but recent events have caused a change
in my heart end quote
while that's a respectable stand to take
the bosses at Universal Pictures
probably wished Carrie had figured that
out before taking the role
icky drunk sex passengers is a science
fiction adventure starring Jennifer
Lawrence and Chris Pratt
despite the star power of its cast it
didn't do very well at the box office
partly due to backlash against a crucial
plot point that involves a startling
disregard for the consent and personal
autonomy of one of the characters which
wasn't helped by Jennifer Lawrence
admitting that she spent the sex scenes
too drunk to remember doing them she
told CNN she had jitters about the shoot
because it was going to be her first
time filming a sex scene and also felt
guilty about doing so with Pratt who's
married quote I got really drunk but
that led to more anxiety because I was
like what have I done
I don't know and it was gonna be my
first time kissing a married man and the
guilt is the worst feeling in your
stomach and quote that leg cross in
Basic Instinct Sharon Stone plays writer
slash murderer Catherine Tramell who
uses her wits and sex appeal to easily
manipulate the men around her especially
in the iconic scene where by simply on
crossing her legs and mm flashing the
cash during a police interrogation she
completely reverses the balance of power
it's nice
[Music]
which is sort of ironic because
according to stone the scene itself
turns out to be born of manipulation and
a violation of consent Stone claims she
was asked by director Paul Verhoeven
to remove her underwear because the
flashes of light were messing up the
shot she was assured there would be no
nudity visible on camera and didn't
discover she had been tricked until she
saw the finished film in a room full of
other people she responded by slapping
Verhoeven who has publicly denied stones
claims saying it's a lie there is a wall
there in the Phantom Menace Terence
Stamp plays Chancellor valorum who's
assured out in favor of the secrets if
Lord Palpatine thanks to a vote of
no-confidence from Queen Amidala played
by Natalie Portman
it's about as exciting to watch as an
actual Senate hearing but it's important
to the overall plot for what passes for
one stamp signed on to the movie for the
sole purpose of getting to act with
Natalie Portman however when he actually
arrived on set Portman was nowhere in
sight and stamp was directed to aim his
dialogue towards a piece of paper on the
wall instead he told indieWIRE it was
just pretty boring which not
coincidentally also sums up the entire
movie thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to